[Music]
the loud kids definitely know how to
make some noise we love Nickelodeon show
but we found some head-scratching
moments join us while we discussed some
plot holes that fans like ourselves have
found in the loud house if you're into
the loud house and other animated shows
be sure to subscribe to the thing and
click the thumbs up button if you like
this video okay here are 10 plot holes
in the loud house that left fans hanging
butterfly effect one fan on reddit was
confused by the explosion in the loud
house episode the butterfly effect
spoiler alert
you may want to check out the episode
before watching this video all cut up
okay here we go
jazz 114 had a lot to say about the
explosion in this episode the vid said
it seems that the entire chain reaction
started from an explosion in Lisa's room
which blasted into Laurie's room but the
stairs between the two rooms are missing
this fan thinks maybe the explosion was
strong enough to blast through the
stairs and the animators were just too
lazy to add them in another redditor who
goes by the name pac-man taco disagreed
with jazmine 14 this fan even went so
far as to find a blueprint of the house
they explained saying the blueprint
shows that Laurie's closet connects to
Lisa's room because it exists on an
overhang over the stairs as a result
they believe that the hole between their
rooms is perfectly within reason nice
find pac-man taco so what do you guys
think is the hole in the wall in their
rooms a symbol of a huge plot hole or do
the blueprints proof that Laurie's and
Lisa's rooms are connected fed up the
loud house truly had some diligent fans
and they don't mind pointing out every
detail in each episode what proof we
found some plot holes that were pointed
out by Victor the Great and other
contributors of the wiki accom about the
episode titled bed they came up with a
couple of plot holes you might find
interesting see the beginning of the
episode on the outside of the house it's
nighttime then on the inside of the
house when everyone is running down the
stairs it's daytime through the
considering the animators had to draw
eleven characters running down the
stairs we suppose we can forgive this
oversight everybody's heads were on
straight no one came down the stairs
naked so good job Nickelodeon there's a
second plot hole these loyal fans on
wiki a notice at one point Rita says the
family food budget for the week is shot
but then at the end of the episode Lynn
danger says he is going to the store to
get some new Lynn greedy uns so our
question is what did he have to do to
come up with money for those Lynn greedy
ins a jewel heist
moonlighting as a my bitcoins we're
curious potty-mouth in this episode Lily
learned the bad word from her siblings
on the same day she's being interviewed
by doctor shuttleworth of this
Shuttleworth daycare Academy in this
episode dr. Shuttleworth comes to the
loud house to see if Lily is
Shuttleworth daycare Academy material
there's only one problem because of the
influence of our siblings lily has got a
pretty big potty mouth the kids try to
retrain Lily in to using more
appropriate language before dr.
shuttleworth survival but it's no use
so the kids come up with a quick
solution they decided to swap loli out
replace her with Lisa apparently due to
some sort of nuclear experiment gone
wrong Lisa is bald and toothless she
agrees to pretend to be Lily for the
interview to avoid any accidental bad
words from offending dr. shuttleworth
the siblings make the switch but even
with a bald head and gummy grin we think
Lisa looks nothing like Lily and these
wikia contributors agree flat bowl lily
has big curious baby eyes while Lisa has
little black tops without her glasses
Lily has a little tough to blunt hair on
the top of her head while Lisa is
completely hairless this woman is a
doctor right and she can't tell the
difference okay eleven lousy leaping
when Christmastime rolls around the
Louds are noisier than Eddie who down in
who-ville maybe that's why their
next-door neighbor mr. grouseman old
Grinchy omen the loud kids have had a
rocky relationship with mr. Krauss for
quite some time it seems every
childhoods got a mr. grouse this one
yells it allows for making too much
racket like all the time but when
Lincoln's accidentally launches his cool
red sled into mr. grouses yard that kid
is devastated he knows that once a toy
goes into that yard it's never coming
back cut to a montage of mr. grouse
holding onto various loud kid belonging
saying my yard my property what a scream
but Lincoln still finds a bit of
compassion for mr. grouse when he
overhears him talking to a family member
on the phone apparently mr. grouse has a
large family and he can't afford to
travel to see them for Christmas
when Lincoln hears this he and the
family pitch in to give him the gift we
all wish we could give our annoying
neighbors but one-way ticket out of town
if they were really trying to be friends
with mr. grouse when they have swung for
a roundtrip ticket that's not a very
subtle hint April Fool's rules according
to this episode April Fool's Day is a
pretty huge deal at the loud house you
know the same way Armageddon is a big
deal actually we're pretty sure
Armageddon doesn't even come close to
the wrath of Luanne on the first day of
April kids and parents alike are
wrapping themselves in bubble wrap and
hiding him bunkers to escape the litany
of pranks launched by this young
psychopath they all try to stop the
mayhem before it has a chance to begin
by locking Luanne inside a crate on
April Fool's Eve they'll celebrate by
laughing heartily at a few clever crate
puns before going to sleep peacefully
trusting that all the prank plans have
been foiled but when they wake up in the
morning they discover that Luanne has
chewed herself free from the metal crate
say what ok we know from all the insane
pranks you played on her poor family
members that this girl is crappy and
like animal left are smart but as one
fan pointed out they never address how
she got out of the crate dude that is
one scary inmate and while we're at it
where the heck did Lennie end up when
she followed those fake science falsely
leading her into the kitchen making the
grade in this episode Lisa decides
kindergarten isn't challenging enough
for her so she skips ahead to 5th grade
where she sits next to Lincoln and ruins
his social life with her pro school
anti-fun agenda when Lincoln convinces
Lisa to be more average Lisa invents a
collar that sprays her in the face if
she says anything intelligent all of
that is pretty believable for a cartoon
the plot hole we found is the way all
other adults rely on Lisa for basic
things they could do for themselves
for example after Lisa's transition
average status the whole family spits
their food out in unison completely
disgusted by dinner
the reason because Lisa usually helps
Lindsay near out with metric conversions
for the recipe um ever hear of Google
dad then their pop-pop gets stuck
waiting at the train station because
Lisa is the only one who can figure out
the complex algebra story problem in
order to figure out his arrival
Farida really mom it never occurred to
you to check the arrival times and then
there's the kindergarten teacher who
needs Lisa to cure the whole class of
strep throat okay seriously why are all
those kids at school with strep throat
relying on a fellow kindergartner to
cure them has no one heard of
antibiotics on this show brawl in the
family with eleven siblings sharing a
house there's bound to be some scuffles
they all have to share one bathroom they
do things on purpose to annoy each other
and they really get on each other's
nerves sometimes it's so bad Lincoln
prefers to room in a hollowed-out linen
closet just so he can have his own space
it's small but at least he doesn't have
to share a room like his other siblings
two things are really escalate in brawl
in the family when Lori and Lenny buy
the exact same style of dress from the
mall these two sourpuss sisters go at it
activating what the loud kids call the
sister fight protocol the remaining loud
crew strapped on walkie-talkies and cut
into action making sure Lenny and Lori
did not cross paths in the hallway they
even took over Lincoln's bedroom to use
as a safe haven for one of the sisters
while the other occupied the girls
shared bedroom the kids act like this
protocol has always been in place but
his fans have pointed out the sister
fight protocol was never implemented in
other episodes where the siblings fight
take space invader for example Lucy and
Lana are at each other's throats and the
kids all just stand in the hallway
eavesdropping where's the sister fight
protocol for that fight X peeved this
episode centers around the loud families
pets the animals are happy playing with
the loud kids and everything seems to be
just dandy until a new dog shows up
Lana finds a stray at the park who looks
like a little fluffy white ball
he's so round and furry they all have a
hard time distinguishing his face from
his but nevertheless they all fall in
love with the new furry stranger and
subsequently ignore their other pets the
disgruntled pets devise a plan to get
the mutt kicked out of the house so they
can go back to getting all the attention
their first plan is to break the lab
parents vase which the folks received as
a wedding present their plan is to blame
it on the new furball vase shatters on
the floor but their mother couldn't be
happier she says she has been wanting an
excuse to get rid of the vase
Rita even feeds the dog a treat not that
and Rita but here's the mistake fans
found in a later scene the base is
perfectly intact and back on the table
so Rita hated it so much why was it
glued back together or did the animators
forget that the vase was already
destroyed whoops no such luck
in this episode Lincoln is tired of
going to all of his sister's activities
I mean think about it he has ten sisters
so his calendar is totally packed with
rodeos pageants open mic nights and
other various obligations it's natural
that this little dude was once a time to
himself so he convinces his family that
he is bad laughs and they will leave him
alone for a while and they do they
really leave him alone
it starts with Lincoln being uninvited
to all family activities and outings
then eventually they make Lincoln sleep
outside
so his bad luck won't spread to the rest
of the family not cool guys but as one
fan pointed out this totally contradicts
with another episode entice advise the
parents said they would never get rid of
any of the kids and they certainly
wouldn't make any of them sleep in a
pile of leaves like Lincoln did no such
luck
his family banishes him so hard he
actually starts to believe you really
have bad luck supercars fans after Lynne
hit the home run and her team wins the
ball game Lincoln is finally able to
convince the family that he is good luck
and they totally agree with one caveat
he's gotta wear the squirrel suit
everywhere the green house in this
episode Lincoln's teacher gives the
class an assignment to reduce the amount
of energy they use in their home so they
can save the polar bears but then
Lincoln comes from a family of 13 people
it proves a lot more challenging for him
than it is for his other classmates we
think Lincoln's teachers should have cut
him a bit of slack considering there's a
small village living under his roof
anyhow Lincoln asks his family to
undergo some pretty extreme changes in
order to keep his home even the green
and eco-friendly every time one of his
siblings for this he shows him a picture
of a cute little polar bear cub sitting
on a tiny iceberg and they cave in but
when the bunch finds out that Lincoln is
hiding in the basement with his friends
playing video games with the air
conditioner on fair more than a little
miss Lincoln has to find a way to keep
his siblings from disowning him while
also keeping his house in the green so
he powers the house with the kinetic
energy he creates from pedaling an
exercise bike to keep them in the greens
there's only one problem we're pretty
sure there is no way one little boy
could power a whole house full of 13
people we're still fans of the show
anyhow and there you have it 10 plot
holes in the loud
that left fans hanging from us here on
the things thanks for watching
[Music]